oi gente boa tarde a tudo ou nada
poderia ser quente ou frio poderia ser
branco ou preto ou qualquer uma destas
opções de contraste ea oposição extremas
eu acho que não sou uma pessoa nem de
brancos em de preços são mais de 15 anos
e das suas nuances esta podemos é a
imagem que o espelho devolve mas por
vezes é mais enfermos refletida no
espelho não é a que corresponda à
verdade quando comentava com amigos
próximos queria estar aqui hoje a falar
sobre este tema e que não me sentia
muito confortável porque não conseguir
resolver nestes extremos objetivo uma
surpreendente reação mas tu és mesmo
isso por como assim tu são mesmo sim
esse daqui é contigo tu és uma pessoa de
tudo ou nada quando a riscos mais até o
final nunca deixes nada a meio à risca
sempre tudo
oi e eu comecei a pensar um pouco
eu fiz uma viagem até ao passado onde me
cruzei com caras que já não via há muito
tempo concentrações e cores e cheiros
que já há muito tempo que não sentia mas
o reencontro com as pessoas foi a coisa
mais forte eu tive a sorte de me cruzar
com pessoas extraordinárias que me
ensinaram tanto
g1
é assim em guimarães em 1978 no antigo
hospital com melhores aqui no sistema
seu filho de domingos de freitas pereira
e de emília pereira pontes o terceiro
filho de um total de quatro dois rapazes
e duas raparigas
a paciente referiu anos 50 o infantário
e a escola primária do alto da bandeira
onde foi aluna da professora dona emília
tem o nome da minha mãe por volta dos
seis anos fui convidado a frequentar os
encontros para a formação de um grupo de
teatro infantil mas acabei de fazer
parte da fundação do rancho folclórico
infantil e juvenil da casa do povo de
creixomil esta foi a minha primeira
aproximação a dessa provavelmente já
nesta altura tinha o desejo de crédito
de estudar dança clássica mas era muito
difícil assumir isso com esta idade e
numa cidade em que a dança era uma coisa
para meninas frequentei a catequese e
nos tempos livres ajudava uma a minha
tia-avó associar igrejas e a decorar
restaurantes e quintas para acolher
casamento
e no oitavo ano em seu mas
principalmente a turma em português foi
dividida em grupos e cada grupo tinha
que fazer poder um texto prematuros e
por isso fazer a sua encenação seria
apresentada na sala de aula o melhor
grupo apresentaria no anfiteatro a toda
a escola o meu grupo não foi o vencedor
nada em marco de 1994 meu pai chegou a
casa com o folheto e disse missão mas só
para ti eu fui olhar para aquilo ainda
hoje me lembro da cor de formato e do
design do folheto onde podemos ler ao
dito oficina de dramaturgia
interpretação teatral direção montes
rodrigues
é claro que aquilo era para mim os pais
são as pessoas que melhor nos conhecem
comecei a fazer hateados todos os dias
desde ações da tarde até até até o
ensaio acabar que por vezes era já no
dia assistir mas nunca faltei as aulas
por mês está errado não pelo contrário
cada vez me sentia mais motivado e feliz
porque aquilo que aprenderam nas aulas
por dia e diferenciar no teatro e a
experiência que tinha no teatro deixava
mais sensível e aberto a tudo aquilo que
me rodeava e uma pessoa muito mais
atenta quanto mais aprendia mais queria
aprender e quanto mais fina a sensação
de saber tudo mais realizava que não
sabia nada
o ponto 7 anos fui com o dito para o
brasil mas antes disso passar por madrid
para fazer um hospital e mesmo antes
disso como podem ver na terceira que eu
tenho fiz a terceira semana da dança de
guimarães em 1996 usada a dizer com
muito orgulho que foi a primeira vez que
tinha feito dança contemporânea no
brasil acabei por não fazer o
espectáculo como interno participei em
toda a montagem técnica seus figurinos
cenografia ajudarem os adereços e depois
chegou o momento de decidir o que é que
queria ser quando fosse grande como se
nós fossemos quando fazemos alguma coisa
mas eu já me explico melhor nesta altura
pensei não quero decidir agora
inscrevi-me em dois cursos ao mesmo
tempo
a frequentar e licenciado em artes
plásticas pintura pela faculdade de
belas artes da universidade do porto
e onde pintava essencialmente figuras
é a primeira vez que eu mostro esse
trabalho nunca na vida mostrar a isto e
desde o final da faculdade que nunca
mais pintei e concluir o curso
profissional de teatro de balleteatro
escola profissional paralelamente fazia
o teatro universitário do porto as
crianças escolas pela proximidade
geográfica da casa dos meus pais não
porque acho que eram as melhores opções
ou não com essa convicção quantos
pertence à classe média a questão
financeira é muito importante é real é
um problema colocar nós temos que te
bater podemos sonhar muito alto mas
temos umas barreiras que às vezes são
difíceis de ultrapassar e é preciso
muita força de vontade para perseguir um
sonho
é a minha força de vontade de conhecer e
mais além fez com que fundasse uma
companhia de teatro de rua fazemos
animações e espetáculos e de situações
hilariantes a ganhar um grande à vontade
no contato direto com o público uma
capacidade gigantesca de improviso a
cada situação pode ser tirada de um
filme de um de um livro de ficção se
amigos para toda a vida que ainda hoje
estão os meus pilares
a paz aí muitas horas de cara pintada de
patos coloridos em cima de umas ondas de
um metro de altura animar centros
comerciais e técnicas festas de
aniversário casamentos inaugurações de
loja a distribuir claires para a
sensibilização da reciclagem e da
reutilização a política dos três erres
o e lembro-me perfeitamente de estar um
dia vestido com um fato de letra e por
cima tinha um fato esponja a imitar
embalagem em plástico do iogurte e uma
criança olha para mim mesmo assim mas um
augusto de que e outro lado diz não eu
gosto magro não estás a ver mas estou a
perder mas ou talvez não esteja porque
este foi um dos momentos mais
importantes do crescimento pessoal e foi
com este trabalho que eu consegui juntar
dinheiro para estudar para inglaterra e
onde fizer as menores que lavar design e
aperfeiçoei muitíssimo o meu inglês tudo
everything
é isso do momento de me tornar adulto
durante muito tempo questionarmos sobre
o que era ao sobre o que faço porque
aquilo que somos e fazemos não é a mesma
coisa agora por vezes respondemos como
fazemos para nos perguntamos quem são
claro que o que somos influência muito
aquilo que fazemos e isso ainda muito
mais evidentes quando somos artistas mas
não é só é uma questão de acreditar
quando terminar os dois cursos tive a
oportunidade de integrar um espetáculo
de dança contemporânea de zilpa isabel
de aves produto variados companhia e
apresentado no grande auditório do
rivoli teatro municipal foi a primeira
vez que se diz desta clássica que era o
aquecimento para os ensaios eu tinha 24
anos
e tal forma marcante que tentei saber
mais pesquisar mais conhecer mais sobre
este corpo pode ser um veículo
comunicante e inscrevi-me no curso de
pesquisa e criação coreográfica do fórum
de santana para concorrer ao curso eu
tinha de fazer a maldição e audição
consistia numa aula de técnica que
ninguém foi dirigido pela bailarina e
coreógrafa margarida bettencourt durante
audição e se sentindo completamente
frustrado porque não conseguia fazer
nada
e depois alguma entrevista que foi muito
acesa porque eu dizia que para ser
curiosa a senhora precisar eu queria era
dançar mas calma eu fiquei no curso e a
margarina do concurso e as matas editar
que eu podia dançar não com um porco que
estava educado e por explicado pela
dança clássica outra qualquer desde a
infância mas por um corpo ainda com
muitas limitações mas que eu podia
transformar essas limitações em
identidade e individualidade desde essa
altura no final desse curso construir o
meu primeiro espectáculo chamava-se
pesou estreou no festival da fábrica
acertar 16 anos e desde então tenho
criado muitas coreografias e tenho tido
cenas com vários capítulos como aqui
aparecia no jornal expresso eu como uma
possibilidade a seguir vem confirmando
eu consegui convencer o meu pai entrar
num dos meus espetáculos
a trabalhar em diferentes formatos com
diferentes pessoas e discentes presos
mas a vontade de continuar com aprender
e a ter mais conhecimento suficiente fiz
o curso destinação da fundação calouste
gulbenkian constrangeu a claudinete com
o tipo de aluno em na bélgica e em
itália posso dizer que sou coreógrafo
entre muitas outras coisas que vou
fazendo como ser professor ou setor como
a si dizem mas as outras coisas é melhor
não falar delas aqui porque não é o
momento ou se calhar até porque isso é
sobre o tudo eo nada e disseram que eu
era um rapaz de tudo então sem sobretudo
vamos a isso só cenógrafo dos clã e
participo em todas as suas encenações
produções fotográficas direciona tudo
todo o material que eles divulgam
em 68 nação do nome cardoso durante dez
anos e tive oportunidade trabalhar com o
ator gigantesco e eu próprio fotógrafo
esta é uma das fotografias fui atuar
numa produção do teatro alla rio em
paris e percorrer esperança a
representar em francês e fizemos uma
relação da peça em italiano em que foi
apresentada no teatro san carlo em
itália são figurinista
o cabeleireiro quando é preciso realizar
videoclip
e até se lê na moda lisboa e cheguei a
coreografar o cristiano ronaldo para um
anúncio publicitário
em todas as coisas que faço tens a na
tintura na fotografia na gravura
influenciam aquilo que faz
inevitavelmente aquilo sul mas a minha
vida não sei que sou feita de tudo
também houve nada até que eu não fui
amor à primeira vista mas do nada no
amor falei num espectáculo chamado até
comprava o teu amor mas não sei em que
moeda se estás esta transação e que era
dirigido por joana carvalheiro no meu
trabalho o nada no amor também está
presente seja no espetáculo sol em que
as pessoas caem de amor when i fall in
love
g1
ou seja no se alguma vez precisares da
minha vida vem e toma alguém que entrega
a sua própria vida por amor nada
olá seja numa não história um espetáculo
inspirado no litro de diesel e ideias em
que ao abandono e ficamos tem nada
é ou não é apenas alguém que busta
incessantemente a felicidade
o acidente um casal à beira do abismo em
decomposição tudo e nada
hoje mas tive muitos muitos momentos de
tudo esta fotografia é um espetáculo
chamado ícone venceu um prémio na
alemanha em 2007 e eu não percebi que
tinha ganho o prémio porque eles estavam
apresentar o concurso em alemão e eu não
tinha percebido que era o vencedor
em outro momento de tudo foi dirigir uma
companhia em moscovo sim selecionado
entre mais de 100 coreógrafo europeus
como estepe e eu fiquei durante um ano a
dirigir em moscovo esta companhia
e em que fizeste espetáculo chamado far
away from each other
o carnaval uma produção para a companhia
nacional de bailado em que tive o prazer
de trabalhar com mais de 40 bailarinos
com 12 compositores contemporâneos que
fizeram composições originais para o
espetáculo
e aí
a ser nomeado como o melhor espetáculo
do ano a bala estoy uma produção simples
para guimarães capital da cultura
receita e três vezes que não queria
fazer esse lado estará que ficam vencido
foi considerado o melhor espectáculo do
ano pelo público e pelo jornal expresso
a partilha de uma composição musical de
dez 20 sesc
é um foi nomeado para o prémio spa um
tudo que depois resolveu nada porque não
ganhei mas ganhei as penas não com o
abalar história mas com outro espetáculo
chamado margem tem um espetáculo
inspirado nas capitães da areia de jorge
amado mas como está está joana traseiro
e que fala desta realidade que são os
que tem tudo e os que não tem nada
é mas a vontade de continuar a aprender
saber cada vez mais despediram outros
criadores mantém-se comigo até hoje e
oi e a certeza há 2 anos atrás concorrer
a uma nova bolsa para estudar para fora
porque queria aprender mais não queria
ficar em fórmulas em coisas que já
conhecia em uma bolsa da fundação
calouste gulbenkian e fiz em viena na
áustria a estudar esta era a minha turma
cada novo projeto é um desafio constante
não gosto de repetir fórmulas não gosto
de lugares que já conheço gosto de
arriscar tudo
o hino drama esta produção eu tentei
e aí por favor
eu peguei numa festa teatral chamada
seis personagens à procura de um autor e
da tiragem das palavras ficaram só os
gestos e as emoções as sensações a
poesia é
e aí
[Música]
e enquanto a crítica não podia ser
melhor vitória o ponto retirar os
objetos no terceiro andar e caiu de pé
afinal arriscar vale a pena em cada novo
projeto a risco espalhar olhei para a
próxima falhará e melhor isto já
conhecemos do backup on
e enquanto preparava esta apresentação
dizia para mim que não devia aceitar
isto que me atende demasiado as coisas
que não posso ter tudo que não posso
fazer tudo que eu não posso estar em
todos os lugares mas depois pensei não
eu tenho que fazer
eu posso não tentar fazer tudo mas quero
fazer o máximo de coisas possíveis
enquanto que estiveste a vida passa
demasiado depressa e eu quero fazer tudo
em pensamento e como dizia o benny que é
um adolescente que eu conheci que vive
num bairro de lata na segunda cidade da
trafaria almada tem umas casas sem
saneamento básico 15m victor hugo a vida
é uma laje muito obrigado a
e aí